mixa punkt geht mir so offen sagt und
zwar ist das hier
ich habe jemanden tolle kleiderschrank
wenn ich jetzt nicht immer wieder mit
dem video habe aber ihr kennt man ja
jetzt schreibt er meine kommentare
deinen kleiderschrank scheiße das tomtom
start ups an etwas glaubt willkommen
beim ein video und zwar gibt es heute
einfach mal von mir ihr habt ja auch
schon vom titel gesehen es geht ich hab
jetzt über vier jungs alleine fast jungs
mit mädchen heute gibt's halt dieses
jungs in einer beziehung vs mädchen eine
beziehung der ist mir so viel zu 1
gefallen und weil da gibt's auch
wirklich enorme unterschiede und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß und falls
doch verkaufen zweiten teil abschreiben
die kommentare oder hinten noch nach
oben und wie schon gesagt viel spaß mit
dem video
wir fangen erst mal ganz locker an und
zwar ist punkt 1 dieses mit dem handy
beschäftigt sein und der partner weiß
nicht was man macht was ich damit meine
ist hier dass hier viel spaß und was
machst du so mach ich schreib grad nur
so ein bisschen mit einem guten freund
von ich wäre der eifersüchtig auf soja
cool wie und du möchtest jetzt gar nicht
mein handy haben will wieso sollte ich
scheiße baue ich bin dafür so ein
bisschen ab ins tor unterwegs weiß wer
so wieder gelegt hat und so kennen wir
ja dann zeig mal ja hier guck doch warum
hast du mit anteile geschrieben als er
ganz ehrlich das war vor einer woche und
nur weil ich wusste was wir in mathe auf
haben und schreiben wir schreiben
nächster punkt geht mir so offen sagt
und weiß dass hier verlieren meinen
kleiderschrank gern ich jetzt nicht
immer wieder mit dem video habe aber ihr
kennt man ja jetzt schreibt er mal die
kommentare deinen kleiderschrank scheiße
ist okay kann ich mit leben kein problem
aber was nicht drin habe ist natürlich
mega geil auf jeden fall g 2.2 um
anziehen viel spaß du schatz sagt doch
noch kann ich so ein abend rausgehen
stellt euch ein bevor ich habe lange
haare weil sonst wird es keinen sinn das
ist mir nicht schick genug auch nicht
schon wieder das gleiche bitte nicht
wieder in seinen hässlichen hemmt so
besser irgendwas fehlt da noch probleme
noch mal noch etwas schwarzes drüber
alter
willst du mich verarschen ja weiter
nehmen dieses eklige was wenn ich wie
das heißt teil
ganz ehrlich mir scheissegal was wir
zusätzlich ziehen das jetzt so an ob du
zufrieden ist oder nicht ist mir so ihr
müsst euch mich jetzt als frau vorstellt
ja sonst irgendwas keinen sinn also pass
auf du schatz sag doch mal kann ich so
heute abend rausgehen
was ist ob ich so ausgehen kann mensch
so gut aus wie das durch und wieder
unsicher ich glaube ich ziehe mir doch
was anderes an
wieso fragst du mich dann überhaupt ich
habe jetzt auch angefangen beatbox
libanon spaß ich weiß wird die
schwestern gut ich will gar nicht lange
weiter beatboxen wir machen weiter mit
pole nummer drei und zwar handele sich
bei punkt nummer drei
könnt ihr den sehen ja gucken fernsehen
geil
okay ist halt wenn man alleine fernseh
gucken ist es geil ansonsten ich was
damit meine
abchecken hier ich mache ein bisschen
fußball manchmal shop den queen gucken
aber was ja okay hier schalten
danke ich mache mir stinkt wie können
wir nicht auch mal fußball gucken
komm bitte komm bitte wir müssen immer
dieses wie ist das shopping queen gucken
shopping queen
ich schlafe dann einfach das war jetzt
punkt nummer drei und ich würde sagen
falls ihr einen punkt nummer vier kennt
schreibt mir denn unten in die
kommentare würde mich sehr freuen
ansonsten aber eben schon gesagt weil
sie bock auf teil zwei klassen daumen
nach oben da wirklich sehr freut
ansonsten instagram so war es ein weil
sonst in der video beschreibung
blockbuster alle voll man so viel spaß
und hier geht es weiter mit meinem
letzten video das war mein erstes mal in
einer disco auf mega lustig okay geht
aber knapp
und ansonsten arbeitete bis mittwoch